-[ Heavy sigh ]
Hi, everyone.
It's Jimmy Fallon.
Welcome to another edition
of "The Tonight Show
At Home Edition."
Today is Friday
and I know every day kind of
feels the same, a little bit,
but, today kind of feels
like a Friday again.
First time in a long time,
I think, you know?
And it's been a week.
It's been, you know,
a lot of time, but,
I have no plan
for the weekend.
Normally, I'm...
pumpin' it up.
"Let's go to the beach.
Let's go to the play.
We'll do something,
then we'll have a play date!
We'll do this;
we'll dah dah."
Nothing.
I got nothing for the kids.
So the kids have that
to look forward to --
absolutely [ Laughing ]
nothing this weekend.
We're staying at home
like we're supposed to do
and it's kind of fun,
in a weird way.
It's freeing.
I'm actually, uh,
happy to be here,
lucky to be here and safe and...
that's what I'm gonna do.
And I'm gonna try not to,
you know,
overthink everything and take
every day one day at a time.
I thank you all
for watching.
I thank NBC for airing this.
YouTube, for airing it
on YouTube as well,
for the people that don't
have cable or a TV.
They can watch our shows.
Thank you for donating.
State Farm.
Our good neighbors
at State Farm.
Where is that?
There it is.
Winnie wrote this out.
Kind of rushed it today, I feel.
-[ Laughing ]
-Redcross.org/statefarm.
State Farm said they'd match
up to $200,000 this week
in donations.
That's $400,000.
We're very close
to reaching $200,000,
I'm very happy to say.
[ Clapping] I love you guys.
That's awesome.
So, that means $400,000
have been donated to Red Cross,
thanks to you guys.
They matched --
They matched your donation.
Thank you to our neighbors
at State Farm
and our friends at Red Cross
are so, so thankful and happy.
We talked to them today
and they wanted
to let everyone know to please
give blood, if you can.
I'm not hearing Winnie.
-Why are you doing that?
-I thought that was Gary.
I was like, "Wait.
Gary can open the door?"
-No.
-[ Laughs ]
-Who is that?
-I want inclusion!
-Oh, my gosh!
Guys, I thought
you were already upstairs.
Hi. Nice to see ya.
-Hi.
-Oh.
-Wait. Give it to me.
Hi, guys.
-Hi.
-Anyways, if you can --
I'll close the door.
Don't worry.
-[ Laughing ]
[ Running footsteps ]
-Hey.
-[ Laughing ]
-I was try-- Sure.
[ Piano playing ]
-She got the note about...
[ Laughs ]
-[ Heavy sigh ]
-...putting her coat on.
-[ Laughing ] It was
so quiet for a second.
It was so quiet for a second.
[ Sigh ]
Anyways, if you can give blood,
please give blood.
They need blood donations,
please.
And my guest tonight,
Miley Cyrus, [ Clap ]
the coolest kid in school,
has been doing a show
on Instagram Live for the past
three weeks, a talk show.
So she now knows what it's like
to be a talk show host
and so, I wanna talk
to her about that.
Also her foundation is
happyhippies.org.
Oh, Winnie, come on.
This is --
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, come on.
Anyways, that's supposed
to say happyhippies.org.
They're doing amazing stuff
for homeless youth,
but they're switching up their
initiative for this pandemic.
You'll see what she has to say.
She's great.
Also, we have
Rachel Brosnahan, who,
covenanthouse.org
is her charity.
Please give to that.
We're talking to Rachel,
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
And then, we have music
from Lewis Capaldi!
[ Clapping ] My man!
[ Scat singing ]
I love that song so much.
♪ I need somebody to heal ♪
♪ Somebody to love ♪
[ Mumbling lyrics ]
♪ Now the day bleeds ♪
♪ Into nightfall ♪
Thank you, Frannie.
Anyways,
he's on the show tonight,
performing a song
from that album.
I love Lewis Capaldi.
Guys, let's start the show.
It's Friday,
"Tonight Show."
Let's do a mono,
monologue, right now.
♪♪
Alright, welcome
to "The Tonight Show
At Home Edition."
Well, guys, it is Friday, so,
congrats on getting through
another workweek on Zoom
without your boss noticing
you're drunk or stoned.
Listen to this -- There's
a petition gaining momentum
to name Dr. Fauci
People magazine's
Sexiest Man Alive.
You know these are crazy times
when the Sexiest Man Alive vote
is gonna come down to
Dr. Fauci and Joe Exotic.
♪♪
If Dr. Fauci doesn't win,
he should at least get
People magazine's
Sexiest Man Trying
to Keep You Alive.
♪♪
That's good.
CNN's Chris Cuomo said
he's lost 13 pounds in 3 days
due to coronavirus.
So, it's official --
I definitely don't have
coronavirus.
♪♪
My man boobs looking weird
-[ Laughing ]
-in this light?
I'll just do this like this.
I saw that more than 12,000
people just applied
to be a NASA astronaut.
Yep. Everyone spent two weeks
with their family and thought,
"I gotta get out to space."
♪♪
Sir Andrew Lloyd Webber
is now streaming Broadway
shows online for free.
My wife will probably
enjoy that more
than me singing "Phantom" songs
with a surgical mask
covering half my face.
♪ Slowly ♪
[ Singing indistinctly ]
♪ I am in a sewer ♪
♪ Trying to find love ♪
Never saw "Phantom."
I can only assume
that's what it was, right?
He live in a sewer?
-[ Laughs ]
-He has a mask or something.
♪♪
I get it.
People love -- The heart wants
what the heart wants, you know?
♪♪
I saw Tom Brady
is moving his family
into Derek Jeter's
mansion in Tampa.
Though it's not
a done deal, yet.
First, Jeter smartly wants
to run a credit check on Brady
[ Laughter ] and get first
and last month's rent up-front.
Very smart.
You never know, man.
[ Laughs ]
Dwayne Johnson posted
a video on Instagram
about washing your hands,
where he's shirtless,
in just a towel,
and rapping a song from "Moana."
Yeah. When Dwayne
does that, it's fun,
but when I do that, it's
"Dad, you're ruining
homeschool."
♪♪
And, finally,
according to scientists,
mice can actually make facial
expressions based on their mood.
Americans heard that
and were like, "That's great.
Any word on the cure
for coronavirus?"
♪♪
Mice can --
That's our monologue
for tonight.
Hey, I think it's time
for "Thank You Notes"!
Girls, get down here!
Help out Daddy!
[ Funk sting plays ]
-Hey, guys.
Today's Friday and,
even though we're quarantined,
it's still a day
where I check my inbox;
return some emails;
and, of course, I send out
thank-you notes.
[ Laughing ]
Well, I was wondering
if I could write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now.
[ Laughter ]
Frannie, can I get some
thank-you note writing
music, please?
[ Tender theme plays ]
That's good; that's good.
That's good.
Thank you, wearing a hat,
for being the new
taking a shower.
[ Whispering ] Go.
Good job.
Thank you, home gyms,
for making me realize
that every time I said,
"If I only had more free time,"
I was just lying to myself.
♪♪
Thank you,
making homemade pizza.
Yes, it takes much longer
than delivery
and involves way more effort,
but, in the end,
it tastes terrible.
♪♪
-Are you ready?
-Mm-hmm.
Winnie, perfect.
♪♪
-Thank you,
tracking a package,
for being
the closest thing I have
to watching sports right now.
"Oh.
Oh, it's in Iowa!
The package made it
to Iowa, guys!" Okay.
♪♪
Thank you, the phrase
"How you holdin' up?"
for being the polite way
of asking someone,
"So, are you also
on the brink of insanity?"
-[ Chuckle ]
-Hm?
-Yeah.
That's perfect.
Don't touch.
Thank you, KFC,
for giving away a million
pieces of fried chicken.
Just maybe don't tell people
it's Finger Lickin' Good.
It's Rubber Glovin'
Finger Licking Good.
♪♪
Thank you, weather app,
for reminding me
that there's weather.
♪♪
Alright. Good.
Last one.
Thank you,
yoga classes over Zoom,
for occasionally becoming
just 16 close-ups of butts.
♪♪
What do you think
of those jokes?
That or this one?
[ Booing ]
-[ Laughing ]
-Guys, we'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
We have [ Laughing ] Miley Cyrus
on the show
and we have Rachel Brosnahan.
-I didn't see this one.
-And Lewis Capaldi.
Thank you, Winnie.
You didn't see that one?
It's funny. Good job, Winnie.
Good job, Frannie.
We'll be right back, everybody.